so no posing no crawford for the giants
here and what it's game two of a day
night double header and up on the mount
it is jeffrey rodriguez who was just
called up today from aaa tom he is
pitching to the big leagues for the
first time since 2019. yeah he's got a
tough assignment today because the
giants control the strike zone as well
as any team their chase rate extremely
low
and he rips through a good heater at 96.
that's a good indication of the life on
rodriguez is fastball because brandon is
a good low fastball hitter
center cut fastball
out to left but schwarber has got space
rodriguez strands a pair of walks and
taxing top of the first four scoreless
lefty connor minez is up on the mound
for the giants just turned 26 years old
he's from hollister california parts of
the last three years in the big leagues
with the giants this is just his 20th
big league appearance in his first start
he's a reliever
since 2019.
the 2-2
this tip toes the line fair
floor is a long throw on the stretch by
belts at first base side retired in
order on a trio of ground ball outs
and the pitch swing and a miss at a
fastball
down goes duvan first strikeout
for jeffrey rodriguez now a swing and a
high high pop up left side of the
infield
playable for starlin castro the third
baseman waiting for that one to come
down he makes the catch of the side
retired major league pop-up off the back
of kurt casallo
and the left field for a base hit
harrison trots to second john gomes
a one out single and the nationals have
two aborted
here comes the payoff
tried to hold back and he goes around on
a pitch up and out of the zone
robles strikes out eminence gets out of
a jam
out to center deepest part of the yard
and it's off the top of the wall
off the very top of the padding
stands up at second base
yeah gabe's trying to get the video room
here but yeah it looked to me like it
just hit the top let's see
yeah that's in play
look like one of the rare change-ups
that rodriguez throws
and yaz was all over it
skips away not even gomez could block
this one
pushes his shrimp skiing to third come
out
delta high lift
up towards left field
forever puts it away
is stranded 90 feet from home as we go
to the bottom of the third scoreless
first time we see a new picture up on
the mound for the giants early on
tonight it's harleen garcia
who will pitch the home third
he goes down easily three pitches all
strikes
and towards the shift a very quick
inning spun by harleen garcia
the giants both then we are off to the
fourth in a seven inning game scoreless
slow skimmer turn a little flip harrison
onto first in time for the double play
he did it again rodriguez
wiggles off the hook let's see if they
want to challenge this
they're holding them up
see if dave kepler wants to hear from
his video room before we go to break
well jeffrey's the only one following
instructions everybody else is running
off the field no challenge from the
giant side of things
an inning ending ground ball double play
to the bottom of the fourth dominic
leone is the giants new pitcher
two up and two down
harrison turns on this center cut
fastball
and drives it into the corner josh
harrison
quickly hustling helmet free into second
base that's how fast he's going
the 3-2
on the ground
and an easy routine play selano on to
first base dominic leona works around a
two-out double scoreless through four
top the fifth pal mcgowan is up on the
mount for the 15th time this year for
the nexus
and he's a good example aaron of how the
game has changed specialty relievers
gets him to chase douglas at number one
saying shake me we're going to throw the
same pitch but let him think we're
getting off
and it gets crawford
mcgowan out of the bowl then retires the
side in order zach latel is up on the
mound
robles finds a base hit and left
turns on a fastball
nationals have some speed aborted first
base with one out
line drive still play aaron
right
ground ball backhand solano flip dubon
to first in time for the double play
they did it again
more ground ball outs through five
scoreless
nationals closer brad hand who got to
save hours ago in game one of the
doubleheader back out there
in play
bouncing to turner harrison on to first
base not in time slater legs it out
and we talked about secondary leads and
how important they are when turner let
this ball bounce one more time
it allowed duvan to really get close to
harrison at second base slater runs well
anyway i'm not sure they would have had
him but and they want to look at this
slide here at second base
and then that's not legal but that looks
to me like a legal slide and they're out
for the headsets
and that's going to
remain as calm
i think they got it right it's worth a
shot
another 2-2
on the ground quickly skimming harrison
has it routine throw on to first base
and brad hand
works a scoreless top of the seventh
takes a late hack at one up and in
and strikes out a really awkward looking
swing from schwarber o2 to harrison
he swings and misses at high gas up and
out of the zone at 96. comes pitch
number 10.
and he rips through a fastball at 97.
mcgee
strikes out the side in order and we are
going to extras
the next batter takes the base that's
casalli shoots this into right field
cassalli is being waved in
and in extra innings this game has its
first run
giant stab runners all around
[Music]
[Applause]
scoring single in the left and the
giants crooked number for the first time
it's two nothing
nationals down to their final three outs
and caleb
who just came off the injured list
yesterday is up on the mound for gabe
kepler
lashed deep out to center field and
this is off the wall
gomes is around and scores
starlin castro punches a ticket deep to
center and it's a one-run game at the
bottom of the eighth with nobody out he
swings at the first
slater backing up in front of the track
castro tagging same story robles robles
takes a hook slide
and now boys he caught up they're gonna
get him you know curt i have no idea
there's just no reason for that no
reason whatsoever
turner a fly ball
popped up
we want to talk about wiggling off the
hook
giants take game two of the doubleheader
they take it in eight innings
as the momentum was shifting towards the
nationals you blink your eyes and his
handshakes give kepler's dugout